what are the steps to developing and
building a character
the steps to developing and building a
character
i have found
has evolved greatly for me but first it
was
uh to sort of tap into
my own um subconscious of just how do i
see this person
i'm super visual and so
uh if a character comes out i can see
that person in all detail um and so
it's first to like understand what that
vision is
and then second it's to
uh ask myself who do i know in the real
world that's like this
um and to use that as a sort of
reflection of of what i see versus
what's in the real world
and
and then also to
you know compare it to other movies um
how has how is a character like this you
know shown up in other films and what's
worked and what hasn't
um and also to ask what is the role of
this character in the story
um and and it's it's all of those but
but primarily it's to draw it back to
reality is um
and not just not just
reality but also to put it in your own
frame of mind is
if i was in this position what would i
do
um or you know if my very best friend
who's very akin to this character was in
this situation what would they do
and i'm also just a strong proponent of
of speaking to those people right like
if you have a character that's that's a
bit of a match with uh with somebody you
know
hanging out with them picking up on
their eccentricities and the ways that
they say things and you know and maybe
even calling them up and saying look if
somebody said this to you what would
your response be
um you should get a release if you have
them you know
literally providing lines for your
script but
but those types of things i found is
that
uh you just get so much nuance and and
you know unique
uh
dimension by
following those steps that um it's
something i try to always employ
here's what the screenwriter of strive
uh
sheree smith said about you
i don't know how it's possible but
physically and emotionally robert
understands what kalani the main female
protagonist in strife is going through
and that is what's important
so can you explain
how you have empathy for characters
so
in reading scripts i always ask myself
is this a story that i know
and what was ironic about strive is that
um
[Music]
or i guess different about strive is
that it was set in harlem and in a world
that on the surface i
shouldn't understand and you know isn't
my story
um
that said
there were some core aspects of that
character
that i really felt connected to
um
so much so that
not just not just sharice but also you
know people
who saw the film came up afterwards and
they're like how
how did you tell this story and um
it felt you know first because because i
sort of understood the pain of of what
that character was facing but but
secondly because i spent a lot of time
you know understanding and being in that
neighborhood and
and um
i guess you know maybe that is a bit of
the documentarian side but but literally
being there i mean doing doing i want to
call it research because it's
it's it's not that but just
um understanding those people that way
of life you know we moved to harlem two
months before we started
uh production and that was for the sole
purpose of
understanding that neighborhood
and what you immediately you know
realize about harlem is it is a it is a
close community and it is a community
that looks to lift one another up
and
uh
and there is so much creativity and and
so much compassion um and so it was the
little things that we witnessed and you
know on the good side and the bad side
uh that we then really tried to bring
into the film so that it felt like at
first and foremost a harlem movie
and then also one about about the main
story main character kalani
how do you do that whether as a
documentarian or for a narrative film
how do you soak up the environment of
the
location that you'll be
shooting
i think it just comes with like
observing being you know
being quiet or or when you need to be or
asking a ton of questions when you need
to be and then there's always those
guides that sort of will take you into
the world
and so asking
hey you know what is it like to to you
know be a [ __ ] in this neighborhood
and then going with a [ __ ] and walking
through and seeing how people interact
with them and
you know one of our
main actors on the film was just not
connecting with the character uh early
on and i i
had him shadow a a [ __ ] and
and the things that he was just able to
to pick up uh about their interaction
was just such a i mean literally walking
into a different world right so his
imagination just can't fill in all of
that detail that that is is actually
there
so that was extremely
beneficial and still he wasn't you know
fully there and so i sat him down
um you know not to over simplify it but
i was like you smile too much
you know like this is these are this is
serious you know and um
and so
sort of
you know i i see i see what you mean you
know like and so we dialed that back
just to kind of craft the character that
was a reflection of the world that it
was in
so people when this actor walked around
with the crib people were scared of the
like the the body language and the the
reaction was they were fearful it was so
much respect paid to this person that
whether they were crips or whether they
were bloods they would cross the street
and you know
and shake his hand and you know not not
bow but you know sort of lower their it
just
it was
it was clear that this was a very
respected person
um and on the opposite side that he also
respected the community and that he was
there looking out for people and
checking on people
and and it's those it's an understanding
of those relationships and sort of why
these people
uh are there and and and how they
interact with the community that
ultimately sort of brought the spine out
of the character that then made it
playable
how do you create characters that are
raw
that are memorable mesmerizing
i think that is a very
difficult
question to
uh answer a very difficult thing to do
i mean we certainly interact with people
that
we have found like that's quite a
character right like wow like i would
never have thought to think of the world
like this or to say something like that
and that can come out in two different
ways it can either come on
literally you know trying to get as much
of that person into
onto the page and into the character
it can come up come through just having
a phenomenal imagination and
channeling you know something like that
um or it can come in having a really
good actor and asking them to bring
themselves um asking to run improv i
mean there's certainly i was just
watching a thing about jonah hill on
wolf of wall street and there was so
much improv that he brought and that's
jonah right like that's him coming on
and so
i think
it it's there's multiple ways to do it
but it's um it's something that needs to
be very concerted to to be able to pull
off successfully
so the way that a director would try to
soak up a location
uh same thing with trying to soak up
various
sort of composites of people indeed yeah
um i mean in harlem or
you know even around la i mean i've
certainly met like very dynamic
characters and uh
um and so yeah it would be
you know first asking them permission
you know
can i can i lean on on you and sort of
put you into a into a film and who you
are
um
and and that can come early in the
writing process or that can come from
taking one particular character and
wanting to kind of spice things up a bit
and reworking the script um or just
hiring that person and saying look like
these are the lines but we ultimately
hired you you know write the objective
of each scene and and that's the way
we're gonna run it we're gonna run it as
you and accomplishing this objective to
to move the narrative forward
you